i like the
the video introduction
it's a great way to get started on the
topic
um
thanks for coming on the last day of
class and
um i wanted to talk about
uh to reflect on a collection of work
that we've done as michael mentioned
supporting collaboration largely through
video and
think about it in the angle of
um what is the difference between using
video for
work or for enterprise and using video
for consumer
my most of my research has been focused
on the enterprise or work based video
until recently and
i think it's an interesting example
because
technically it's the same technology
right video calling for video
conferencing or for business versus
skype calling for home it's the same
underlying technology but one of the
interesting things in our research
recently is we've been noticing how the
usage cases are are dramatically
different between
work and home so i want to just reflect
on that a little bit
review
a number of projects that we've been
doing and use that to think about what
are some opportunities this maybe helps
us see in the future
so first a little history
right so
uh the first video
uh technology video phones did appear in
the sort of the consumer space the
famous att picture phone
back in 1964.
uh if you can see they did get the use
case right there's the gram apparently a
grandmother chatting with their child
but this never really took off right in
the consumer space this is back in 1964.
um
interestingly a three-minute call would
in today's dollars be around 200
uh and
the other interesting thing about is
that it was installed in these
essentially
this is uh i'm happy to say this is
before my time professionally so i'm
told this happened in public video phone
booths installed in like the grand
central station in new york and other
public places in these cities so you can
kind of see that the deployment
infrastructure wasn't there to make this
a very ubiquitous technology
they did some commercial some enterprise
services for video phones
in pittsburgh actually my hometown you
know and westinghouse but at its peak
500 people subscribed to the 18t picture
phone and it was kind of shut down as a
commercial business within about a
decade
so it started in the enterprise in the
consumer world video phones um
not in the same area not too lit too
much later there was a workplace demo
famously the mother of all demos in nls
1968 which among other things showed
multi-person video conferencing um and
again
that the technology was there for that
but usage was relatively slow and
picking up
so like i said i've spent in fact much
of my career thinking about how to use
video to support people working together
and largely that's been in the workplace
setting um back in the 90s i did an
interesting video shared drawing
prototype purely video that allowed two
people in potentially different places
look like they're kind of sharing the
same whiteboard
back in
again in the 90s you can tell by that
grainy video quality
one of the first digital desktop
video conferencing technology systems on
some workstations
and
one of the more interesting things we
did is uh use the fact that it was
digital to create some effects this sort
of video window that faded in gradually
rather than popped up on your on your
desktop because you know people don't
pop up and appear in front of your face
they kind of have a sense of approach
and they walk in we wanted to try to
figure out how we could digitally
simulate that by having these video
windows fade in and out
but more recently um
i worked for microsoft research and
microsoft acquired skype uh and that
got our group our research group to
pivot a little bit and think about well
all this work we've been doing for the
enterprise
what would it mean to think about the
consumer or the social the personal
realm we've actually wanted to do that
kind of research for a long time and now
we had a business case you know we now
had a product group that focused on
consumer video let's explore some
some prototypes and some technologies
that would support that i'll talk about
experiences ago another one that you
could find in kai's a project we did at
home proxy which was enabling this sort
of
video messaging at home uh a kind of a
standalone appliance you could walk up
to leave a message and then leave and it
would take care of sending it to the
right person and kind of letting them
find out that there was a message for
them and so
today this is sort of like the pinnacle
of
video conferencing for the enterprise uh
the cisco telepresence system which
advertises itself as kind of making you
feel like you're there i will point out
uh this really only works for the person
in the center that the the person the
center gets the views of when people are
looking at them and when they're looking
elsewhere the other people don't quite
get that sense and it was sort of
optimized for the ceo or the cxo right
so that person sits in the center they
get the optimized views the other people
are kind of supporting to them
but this is hugely expensive
not sure
how you would characterize it in terms
of commercial success and
video in the enterprise has often been
motivated by
saving travel
money right how can you
get this work done with remote people
without actually getting on a plane
spending all that money
and also all the wear and tear on people
and so it's motivation i think has led
to this very
practical or utilitarian
connecting people and this really is
talking heads enabling you to see
talking heads and interact with each
other
while you're conducting business
so um
we did some work and this was published
at this in 2012 where we specifically
asked people who were active using video
both
at work and at home to reflect on their
experiences
this was an
open-ended interview study where we
asked people you know
what what are the things that you
remember doing with video both at work
and at home
and we especially tried to get to elicit
what novel experiences or what unique
things they were doing with video
this we crew recruited
through
basically
an email server screener that went to
both employees in our company and that
sort of mushroomed out to other people
their families
ended up being around you know
international not just puget sound
and
again they had to be active users of
video
and thought that the video was very was
at least moderately important for
accomplishing their work some
demographics about ages and gender
balance
and most of them were
in some sort of social relationship in a
family or in a relationship
so and what struck us about this was
that
most of the interesting things that were
happening or uh see
what people wanted to really tell us
about were the ways they were using
video for at home for personal or for
social reasons um at work there were
sort of cursing mentions about meetings
and things like that but at home there
was this long list of very diverse and
interesting activities i just want to
call out a couple of my favorites
um one
is where is that one working on a
plane together
um where there was a father-son team
and they were the sun was flying his
plane somewhere and it was making a
weird sound when it when the plane
landed so
uh he called his father on his phone and
sort of weaseled it up into the engine
compartment while using the video using
skype and said you know do you think
this is okay can i make it home and the
father kind of they did some
troubleshooting uh using the video on
the mobile phone and and he basically
said yeah i think it's okay and then
they went off so that ability to use
this portable device that's in your
pocket
to connect
visually with an expert and get an
opinion on a kind of a mechanical
problem
the other great example i had i liked
was remote babysitting so this was a
story
where um
two sisters were talking one was
overseas and uh the new the sister here
was a newborn a mother of a newborn and
she was visibly tired of having a video
conference with that person and so she
was there with the baby and they were
talking his sister's due and she was
complaining about how tired she was and
the remote sister i think she was in
japan says you know what
you go take a nap
leave the baby in front of the video
camera i'll call you if anything goes
wrong
and and sort of provided this sisterly
remote babysitting service with
technology that you know they were
confident they could do the alerting if
necessary it was a newborn so it wasn't
gonna run away or anything um and so
they were able to create this uh
this virtual sisterly act of caring for
each other's child even though they were
like halfway around the world and so um
just really interesting ways in which
people were appropriating or using video
technology to make these sort of social
connections
and i wanted to give just a little
example of a compilation that we found
on youtube this is not of our own work
but uh of examples of people doing this
kind of meal
are you enjoying your meal with all your
kids yes i do
it's lovely
so this is
a
everyone has their virtual stations
and where's where's philip sitting
people have places at this table come
near the camera you're getting you have
to say hi to mom
when the evening comes it's not a peak
mickey counts as sleeping okay this is a
military dad reading a story
and this is actually a pre-recorded
thing this is part of her bedtime
routine
i love you
but they have this sort of connection
here we go
another military story of being present
at uh
a birth
here i'll hold your hand and it'll be
like greg holding his hand a nice proxy
act there's your baby boy
you see him okay
can you see him
i can see him
and you can see the emotion around and
then
another example of attending a wedding
remotely
and
and capturing it in pictures is a big
part of demonstrating that oh yeah i was
there
you know she actually bought the
matching dress even though she wasn't
physically there
um so ways in which people are using
video to be there um
for social reasons
so we were really struck by this sort of
creative use of video in the in the
social world and that led us to a series
of projects that i want to kind of touch
on and then re
touch on these various projects
return again to the enterprise to see if
anything interesting has been happening
in the enterprise since then as well and
reflect on some of the opportunities
between enterprise and consumer
okay so the first one video kids this
was enabling
a set of kids to
who had a close existing relationship
how are they using video as a way of
staying close even though they saw each
other kind of a lot
like almost every day as well
this is also work that showed up at kai
by many of my colleagues so the
technology is actually very very simple
asynchronous video messaging tool um
it did support some threading others you
could connect those those individual
messages into conversation threads but
the main goal was to make it as
lightweight and easy as possible
to connect um and we were just using
webcams uh actually it allowed you to
use a webcam and also screen record of
your what was happening on your computer
you could send that as a message as well
and interface again fairly
straightforward this was how you could
kind of keep threads of conversations
together and there was a quick way to
play through the entire thread
so but
nothing a pretty straightforward
interface
we actually had
developed this and given it as a tool
for work at first you know would people
at work use video messaging um and
basically we didn't get very much uptake
there the most interesting thing they
did uh was because we deployed it at one
of the remote geographically remote
sites and they gave a kind of a tour a
visual video tour of their new building
in i think china
but otherwise they were sort of pretty
um
flat messages uh about work but when we
gave it to this group of pre-teen girls
first of all about 200 messages in the
first
day
really quick uptake lots of
conversations
lots of messages sent and a lot of
messages were viewed multiple times it
wasn't it was about
sending and sharing and reviewing and uh
having that connection through the
messages um some of them relatively long
threads of messages 140 or so
but
what was striking is with just how
quickly they used it and appropriated it
and i'll just give a an example of some
of the
the video
messages that they left with each other
now remember this is preteen girls so uh
it's it's a lot of fun for them
yeah go guess what i had for breakfast
this morning
cereal yeah i had cereal again
haley guess what
i didn't have cereal
two pictures that was cereal because you
know
cereal that's a screen recording good
and uh
hi eliza
i love puppets too and i can't believe
you love lady gaga that's my favorite
artist too and look brutal likes lady
gaga too she loves lady gaga okay bye
okay so using that expressiveness of
video
so hi peoples i'm going to show you my
rock collection ready
let's do this thing
okay wanting to be mobile with me okay
did you see
do you see those two things right there
and just playing together watch us roll
in our money okay
ready
set
so what we thought was interesting about
that is their use of video
again not like you'd find in the
workplace but almost like um even though
it was asynchronous
it felt like they were trying to create
a an activity that they were doing
together um so they were remote
and they were asynchronous uh but it
felt like they were creating this kind
of shared play space using video
even though it was sort of messaging
and so um that got us to wanting to
explore what else could we do with video
and messaging or or video
with social people um
and led to another project that we
called experiences to go this is
originally called um
uh
grandma on a box because uh that's what
the telepresence robot that michael
referred to is usually called john in
the box but people didn't like the way
grammar on the box sounded so then we
call it grandma to go
which then broaden because we only had a
few grandmothers that use this but
anyway this was an attempt to take video
conferencing out of the home and into
the places where kids activities occur
because a lot of these was driven of
course by
attending kids activities that might be
sporting events outdoors it might be
birthday parties and special venues
and
frankly one of the critiques about skype
is that often a skype call your sort of
canonical weekly call with uh uncle joe
it often is in the same computer in the
same room week after week connecting
those two rooms and not very much as
interesting is happening
other than the talking faces so we
wanted to try to take that out of the
that kind of those four walls and see
well what could we do by enabling video
conferencing out in the wild
so that led to this
rather
science fair kind of project where we
cobbled together a camera
that a camcorder that allowed
pan tilt and zoom importantly because a
lot of these kids events are kind of
farther away
and could also deal with lighting
we wanted it to be portable it's not
beautifully portable but you can throw
it in a car or take it someplace
and we used skype because that was a
tool that reached a lot of people didn't
have to do any customized install on the
remote side
and we used a 4g hotspot that
allowed it to go virtually anywhere
especially in the puget sound area or
silicon valley area where this work was
done
so this was this portable
video terminal and it had this
affordance that there was a tablet there
that showed the remote person so unlike
when you record something for a
camcorder and you don't see the audience
here we wanted to give the audience a
sense of presence a sense of
being able to come up and interact with
that person
and so
again we recruited people
to take this out and do what they wanted
with and we captured lots of diverse
activity um
fishing birthday parties play centers
and a lot of these were
interestingly
though you might think this is kind of
targeted for remote people a lot of
these were families where
one partner or the other couldn't attend
because of scheduling constraints but
wanted to be involved in in the event so
a case where
the
uh let's see i think in this case the
husband's watching the swim team
practice and the wife wanted to join
remotely
so they're they live in the same city
but scheduling wise it was they wanted
to try this out virtually
and again just a quick sample of what
this looked like this was a fishing a
birthday party held at a fish hatchery
and they were connecting with a
grandmother till that time
they walk up to it and talk to the
grandmother
and in one case
the grandmother could see that they
caught a fish and started kind of
cheering or plotting even before
there was a conversation about it so it
really felt like she could be involved
in that interaction
so just some quotes about how people
felt in this
a feeling of being part of the activity
uh that they were sitting there right
next to them to share in the activity
with their kids uh like they were both
together and and that was exactly
what we were going for is that video is
not just a medium for kind of projecting
a talking head but it's a medium that
allows remote people to be part of an
activity together and it actually led to
a realization that there are many
stakeholders in these kinds of
interactions right so obviously there's
the remote person um
the proverbial grandmother that wants to
be part of a kid's activity and then
there's the local observer the sort of
person that is helping the grandmother
attend and actually oftentimes there's
an interesting social interaction
between those two because usually let's
take the grandmother case usually it's
the grandmother's own child son or
daughter that is you know doing all this
and so
while they're watching five-year-old
soccer which isn't actually a thrill a
minute they would catch up on their
social chit chat right they would have
the usual parent-child discussion as if
they were sitting in the bleachers
together
and the the kids activity was sort of an
occasion to come together on that
so it was important to support that
interaction as well as showing what's
going on with the kids
and then there were the kids the local
people taking part in activity who would
from time to time want to come up and
say something directly to grandma
and also would want to have the sense
that not only the local people there but
remote people are attending as well so
though they're an interesting part of
the stakeholder
and the other stakeholder were the
people around the audience okay so can
we do this in a way that doesn't seem
strange or weird
and this one in particular this was a
high school track and field meet and
this is the one example where the high
school daughter came up and said i don't
want to look weird or something because
you're doing this thing and watching me
and so so she was very aware of the
social context of what it would look
like that this thing was sitting in the
stands watching her
the other thing that happened is that
because they were they were often
local people we actually got a few
conversations between the remote person
and other
bystanders other people who are
attending the event and we wanted to
think about how to afford for that and
that's an interesting question you know
think about this compared to say google
glass where the real person could be
watching something but you have no
awareness of what's going on it's a
little bit like the invisible headset uh
people that you talk to and so this
takes a different
approach by making that remote person
more real or more visible
okay
um the third project i want to talk
about is sharing experiences over video
um this you might think of as watching
tv together or watching video together
again done by a number of colleagues and
a summer intern
and presented at interact in last year
and
this was actually
this had had some interesting parts
about the methodology first we basically
did a survey do you ever try to watch tv
or videos together with someone remotely
and while you're doing that have some
connection like a skype call or maybe
just a phone call so that you feel like
you're watching the program together
so the survey asks if people do that and
if so how they're doing that um this
again started with uh employees at our
company and then mushroomed beyond
and we had just a number of basic
questions about
tell us more about how you do this and
your demographics
an interesting part about the study is
that
the survey
responses came from
full-time employees and
this happened during the summer so there
are a lot of summer interns and there's
obviously an age demographic difference
there and that shows up in how people
kind of use this
the next thing we did
which was interesting methodologically
is just ask people who do this who watch
videos together
the next time you do it
tell us about it through a survey and if
you'd like to
loop us in on a skype call so in other
words they're watching tv together they
have a skype call going with each other
and they make a skype call to one of our
basically um automatic bot skype bots
that records the conversation for
research purposes uh as and we get to
see what's going on in their homes in
this case which is
kind of an interesting thing from a
research point of view because we as
researchers don't have to go
visit all these homes personally they
can just loop us in whenever they do it
uh whenever the time is convenient for
them and we actually don't have to be
there to capture that data
so it was scheduled on their own time
the third part of the study was a lab
study where we actually brought people
in tried a couple different
configurations of doing this uh and i'll
just kind of quickly bruise through that
one is you know when
you're sitting side by side uh another
is that
the remote person appears as a picture
in a picture it's a really small
rectangle on the tv screen so you're
watching the tv and you see the other
person remotely and the third condition
was what we call the proxy condition
where you know you have a screen or kind
of a place dedicated for that remote
person and you're again watching
together um
and a quick example of what this looked
like to show um
what what it feels like to kind of share
those reactions while you're watching tv
together
you know i'm sure you don't want to get
caught up in anything that's illegal
right
so that went by quickly but there was
this comment about oh you wouldn't want
to do anything illegal and and they can
share those reactions and nearly
simultaneously there's a slight delay in
terms of how it was synchronized
so
but the one thing that was interesting
for us is that um
in the survey where we ask you know do
you do this or would you be interested
a small percentage of people did try it
um
and roughly equal percentage said they
wanted to try it um but half of the
people said you know this basically
sounds like too much trouble or
like it wouldn't be satisfying and yet
in the field study or the lab study once
we did give them the actual experience
of trying this um
people said oh you know now that i see
how i could do this i'd like to do this
again
it's just that it suggests that there is
this bit of a hump of getting people
to actually experience it first
and once they see that it is actually
possible with the infrastructure
infrastructure that we have
they would be generally more interested
in trying this again
so that is uh another indicator of the
of just sort of getting over the
the initial hump of well i never thought
i could do that before um but we do have
a technology now that reaches into
people's homes that that could enable
this kind of work
the other interesting thing is that when
you broke down by age obviously more
people in the intern demographic were
doing and trying this than people that
were older
okay
um so
i want to share it about one other
experience
and this is actually the experience that
kind of sold me on
this kind of work
um
so when i went to kai in paris last year
um i made a side trip to this castle
that's sort of nearby in pier falls
and this was at the request of my
younger daughter
who was a big merlin fan i don't know if
anyone else is into this scene at all oh
could so uh as you might have noticed
that castle is the scene for camelot in
the series and my daughter was a big fan
and kind of wanted to see actually she
wanted to see what the real castle was
like and how that compared to the castle
as envisioned in the
tv series because you know as you cut
from room from scene to scene you can
move between rooms and and it has no
relationship necessarily to the real
castle
so
um i took a train and a bit of a
cab ride two pier phones from paris um
and basically took my iphone
added a wide-angle lens that allowed
be able to capture a kind of wider field
of view
earbuds of course
and that sorry that part was what
enabled me to basically have a skype
connection with my daughter back here in
california
additionally i added a look-see camera
that uh was just to kind of have an
asynchronous recording at a higher
um fidelity right to that that she could
watch afterwards um so that was sort of
a separate part there was the
synchronous part that was on skype on
the iphone the asynchronous part was
this had uh worn a video camera
and to boot i was using a digital camera
that she wanted to get pictures of exact
places of
um
and
a little pocket protector just kind of
mounted in my uh pocket in the right way
do you know how hard it is to get pocket
protectors nowadays it's uh okay so this
is what it looked like
right the things you do for your
daughter um
the google cap uh and actually i wore it
because it was the only black cap that i
had to sort of mask the luxie camera if
people wanted to think this was a google
glass prototype i wasn't going to say
anything about that but
anyway but sorry
the main thing right i'm just wearing
this camera in my pocket
using the back camera for it walking
around
chatting on my earbuds with my daughter
we did the time zone difference so that
she did wake up for this and gave her
her tour of the castle
so
a little bit to my surprise i did get 3g
service in this remote part of france
and the call lasted for over two hours
on the iphone battery right
in fact what it was really limited is
that the castle closed before i kind of
got through everything
1618 megabytes of data usage i could
tell on my phone bill uh
and skype more or less
worked throughout the entire time it did
the usual lagging and freezing from time
to time but we were able to have a
conversation and
the audio was pretty good throughout
most of that time
look see on the other hand only lasted
about 40 minutes and that's because the
battery ran out uh after that time uh
luxie at that time
i mean that's been an issue for that and
it got very hot and my daughter directed
me to take over 200 pictures while i was
there okay so uh i asked um i asked the
guy in that was there if they had wi-fi
which would have saved me a lot of money
and maybe made it higher fidelity and
and he said no you know maybe you should
take pictures and show them when when
you get back but we had a higher
fidelity shared experience than mine so
we did this um and this is a picture of
her
watching my wife took this when she was
watching it at home
uh and some comments about that from her
point of view that uh she had the sense
that she got to do this together um she
loved directing my father i suppose you
could stop there but to to take pictures
you know um
uh and through audio
uh she did it wasn't easy to see because
of the blurriness of the video um
and another thing she missed is some of
the other senses right this was only
visual
and
this last comment that you know um
pictures especially digital
uh devices tend to
perfect images
around lighting which is not necessarily
what it really looks like and this is a
a good case in point this is in the
catacombs down in the bottom and the
picture i took from the digital camera
actually did an amazing job of
lightening it up uh whereas in reality
it was almost
you know it was almost dark and you had
to kind of walk carefully through
because you couldn't see
with that amount of uh you didn't have
that sense of light
okay
um
and one of the things that i did as part
of this is i picked up a stone and
brought it back as a sort of memento
that she
would have of going to this visit and
uh you can barely see it i'm holding the
stone right there and when i when i
i
showed it to them and i wanted to bring
up the video or the picture that
corresponded to it um
they sort of they caught themselves
talking this language just like yeah we
were there when you picked it up because
the the video camera was still on when i
picked it up and took it so in fact they
i didn't have to demonstrate this with
the picture they had this sense that
they were part of that uh
that activity
so
uh oh
this is just a quick video example from
the look-see itself so this is head
mounted a warning if you get queasy
watching head mounted video you might
want to close your eyes after a bit but
this is just an example of what that
looked like
so you can see the brim of the hat right
there
and i pull out the camera and see this
is the only way i can talk to her is if
i pull it out and and look at
her
she's guiding me to look at these um
they're the same they look the same
these uh
these uh gargoyle downspouts i'll i'll
point it out to you so she she's she
wants me this one over here
some kids
this actually is the guy that said no
taxi
well i ate lunch at the at the after i
got out and it's connecting
we have a short conversation there
but anyway um she wants to look at this
gargoyle i asked about wi-fi
i said just take pictures and then
fortunately when i get to the spot
skype freezes up because i'm sort of not
in a good spot
my coverage in this pot is weird is late
week so i have to walk back
yeah and that's the other one
that's the other one that goes on for a
while
um so
um
that actually
uh
well
after this this is the experience that
made me feel like huh there's something
here about this connection um and
uh let me let me
skip to head to this one uh
you know when i thought about this in
terms of my experience um
i actually
got a lot of her feedback her excitement
of seeing things through the audio
channel so even though i wasn't able to
see her face all the time
in part because we might have a pretty
close tie we're pretty closely connected
uh i could get that most of that
excitement through the audio without
having to look at her face i would have
liked to have occasionally looked at it
if that was more convenient and so
pulling out of my pocket
was not only in community for me but i
realized that that disrupted her view of
what was going on so i i didn't do that
very often
um
and i did feel a little self-conscious
so right i have this thing in my pocket
i'm walking around and and she wants to
see something and i kind of aim my body
that way and aim back
so not the best interface there um
but the interesting thing is that this
is not a place that i would naturally
have gone
on my own time in in paris france right
but it is something that i wanted to do
together with my daughter and we got
that experience that we actually were
doing something together even though we
were sort of remote i will say that
there was some bystander curiosity of
that um it has a lot to do with
especially the audio i was being trying
to be kind of subtle in that but again
it looked like i was talking to
uh myself i guess
um then just another point she did look
at the asynchronous video afterwards um
again it felt like it recreated the
experience it was much higher fidelity
so she got to look at some of the
details of you know where things had
been cgi'd in in the show versus they
weren't there in real life
and
again this notion of
you know even though it wasn't real time
i felt i was walking around and i caught
myself moving my head around the peak of
the corner i don't know if you've done
this but you're looking at something on
your phone and something goes out of you
and you sort of move it to sort of think
that you can somehow control or get it
back into view because
there's that that um illusion that video
is putting you in that place uh with
them and that you kind of have some
control even though
in this case it was asynchronous and she
couldn't do anything to control it it
did kind of represent that illusion
okay
so
corny sci-fi joke about going back to
the enterprise or the next surprise so
what's been happening in enterprise
space while all this has been happening
in in the consumer space well in fact
there have been these things another
example of robot that michael mentioned
um
about
mobile
uh video in the workplace this is a
technology called the beam
by a company called suitable
technologies that
enables people like me who work remotely
to
physically move around in that place and
participate in meetings
much like other people who are seated at
the table
um and this in fact is a project this is
probably the robot you might have seen
me on uh where we didn't deal with the
robotic movement part we just had a
mobile video
terminal
which is a physical proxy that allows me
to participate kind of have a seat at
the table and a lot of this research
what we found out is the difference that
it makes to have this sense of physical
presence that you you know
if someone turns to the to the proxy and
says well what do you think about that
all those dictating references make
sense and all the the cues that we use
to manage turn taking or manage who's
asking whom um all work because there's
a sort of physical location this is in
contrast to you know speaking at some
black box in the center of a speaker
phone or being kind of glued to the wall
in larger than life form
if you're kind of video conferencing
and so we've been leveraging that and
other companies have commercially looked
into that
kind of one of the more interesting
things is that it's the social
integration of these things that are are
the more surprising things so right does
it really make sense to
see some a video of someone eating lunch
together but it's the fact that you're
doing this eating lunch together with
somebody else or there's also a beam
soccer game that has been done i think
this was willow garage where
they made these things
and
at the most recent kai conference
there was a double robot this is kind of
a more segue-like thing you can buy you
stick an ipad in there and it becomes a
lower cost version of those proxy
and this allowed people to attend talks
in this case um he's turned around and
looking at the person who's asking the
question and this is a different person
attending
kai
at the reception where you're sort of
doing more of this mingling and and
asking these personal questions
and so there is some um exploration of
what does
video look like in the workplace that is
more mobile
more physical
and again
gives this opportunity of being part of
an experience
so
reflecting a little bit on
this enterprise and consumer usage
what have we learned by kind of looking
at these side by side
first of all for me i think it's
interesting that as i said at the
beginning
the technology stack is essentially the
same and it's the social
issues around it that are kind of
driving these different uses so it's a
great illustration of a social technical
system where uh it's the cul it's the
connection the collaboration of both of
them that create these different use
cases
another thing and this is i think true
for both uh enterprise and consumer is
it's not only for geographically remote
i mean you might think of video
conferencing as mainly enabling people
who are in different cities or around
the world to come together but in fact
and what i was trying to convey in this
picture there's a lot of
very local uses of video the proverbial
looking at something while i'm shopping
with and getting an opinion from
somebody else to make sure i'm getting
the right thing
or
very
short usages of snapchat or instagram to
just
convey these sort of phatic messages
that hey i'm thinking about you even
though i'm going to see you when you
come home to dinner i wanted to send
this to you now
so there's a lot of local uses of video
not just for remote
i think mobile does make a difference
both in the personal and consumer you
see all these pictures of the fact that
these mobile devices in our pockets now
allow us to take pictures and share
videos with each other but also in
business where
many of our meetings are happening on
the go and use these mobile devices to
support it but i would also say think
not just of the traditional mobile
device but new forms of mobile devices
um which i think the
telepresence robots are an example of
and and i will say you know i'm not a
fan of the form factor i don't think
that um
these mobile robots are necessarily
going to be the way of the future but i
am intrigued by the kinds of experiences
it enables that i can
be
at a social event or a kind of a work
networking event and have a presence
even though i'm remote
so
one of the things i will say about my
experience at microsoft we're working
remotely although my proxy does a great
job for helping me be part of meetings
and actually being socially integrated
with the team whenever the team does an
off-site or goes to lunch outside
that's where i still feel like there's
room for using some of these
kinds of technologies to enable me to go
along so i think that's an area for
future work
another interesting i think
kind of overlay about this is how
uh the younger generation appears to be
much more comfortable and much more
literate with video than the older
generation and they're using that so the
popularity of things like snapchat and
vine to that that younger generation
feel completely fafsa with um and we had
a recent interview with uh some high
school teenage boys where
they just sort of said yeah you know
you're on a roller coaster ride yeah
sure you just take out a video
six seconds and you're able to share
that with other people this is very kind
of unremarkable i'd say to a generation
of people who are very video literate
and have the devices and the
infrastructure that they've grown up
with that they can just assume that that
you can do that
okay but the one difference i think is
that uh
i think
work connections are relatively elastic
to use an economic term or flexible
right so i have a work problem i walk
down the hall
there's like a half dozen people that
could help me with this problem and i'll
pick the one that's available
and
and accessible and approachable
and so i may not go through great links
to find just the right person because
there's a collection of people that will
do fine
whereas
personal contacts
contacts tend to be sort of inelastic
right i only have one mother and one
father if i want to share something of
my baby with them i'm going to go
through the extra hoops to connect them
and so i think this is what is driving
that more creative usage of video in the
in the personal or the consumer realm
compared to the workplace realm because
there are special people that wherever
they are in the world
will try to figure out a way to connect
them and and that ends up
you know
um
prompting us to be kind of more creative
with with that technology
and so one of the themes of our group's
work has been moving from
talking heads to actually enabling
people to share experiences together
and another way i might say that is that
you know video you might think of it as
connecting people but it really goes
beyond that to giving people who are
already connected
ways to do things together um and that's
the collection of uh projects that we
have been exploring experimenting with
as a group um i think we are definitely
continuing to explore in that mobile and
asynchronous world
but that's i think some opportunities
for future growth
so i think that's it thanks very much
for your attention
and i'm glad to answer any questions
yeah
so um this is really interesting um with
regard to the how it's used in the uh
videos used in the enterprise i mean it
seems like you know two of the
challenges particularly with like global
work is that you know asynchronous so
you do have all the time zone issues um
i know you mentioned like video
messaging because it didn't take off so
i'd be curious to hear more about that
and also it's the fact that formalities
around video is still very much like you
plan these like video conferences in
advance so you can't just like go up to
someone at the next desk or you have to
like right initiate them all right so um
i do think uh
that is what i think
is an interesting opportunity with
asynchronous messaging um so we did a
project that didn't mention this um it
was presented at kai actually in paris
on
i'm sorry two years ago i guess um on
something called what we call time
travel proxy which enabled
what we want to do is allow
asynchronous video messaging to give
that sense of a globally remote person
being there at the meeting so the way it
worked is that i
my colleagues in china
they want to attend this meeting that's
happening in america they record a
message
and send it in during their day
and then
when we have the meeting here i bring
out a laptop or some physical proxy
that's um
always playing a kind of a loop of them
which gives you a sense that they're
there virtually and when the time and
the meeting comes up for their
contribution you know we just sort of
touch their little thought balloon and
that message plays uh as part of the
meeting but the the interesting thing
that we tried with that is something
that we called reaction videos that is
while we're playing that message it's
recording the the the meeting room and
so
that remote person could get a sense of
you know did they get my joke were they
confused did they agree did they
disagree all that natural reaction that
happened in meetings could happen even
though it was asynchronous just by kind
of recording the reaction video
and there have been a couple reaction
video prototypes in the consumer space
on phones as well for social for social
communication
so we did
play with using that to sort of bend
this synchronous asynchronous
boundary so that
we could deal with the time the global
time zone difference and
the question was did both sides feel
like they were kind of part of a meeting
even though this was
kind of divvied up in time and and the
answer was generally that the remote
person felt like at least they were
heard and um
uh
their contribution to the meeting was
paid attention to but getting the um the
feedback back to them is sort of still a
weak link so it felt like we were able
to address one side but not sort of the
reverse side and i think that's an
interesting way of maybe exploring using
um different ways of using asynchronous
messaging to overcome that time zone the
global time zone difference do you think
it could work
for example
you know it's by sending these messages
you can also get like some of the
context around you and
obviously the size is an issue
i mean the problem of course email was
always an option for these people and
and most
uh um
so one of the things that they said that
i thought was interesting is that
the social context of the meeting
being part of the social context of the
meeting gave them a sense that their
contribution was heard whereas email is
kind of a crap shoot nowadays is the
person going to read it are they going
to respond
not as but you know being part of a
meeting especially if you think about um
status report meetings or
uh kind of pair program meetings where
everyone kind of stands up and does
their things things that meetings that
have a a good structure to it and
people's participation is kind of uh
add up sequentially we were thinking
that this could be an interesting way of
adding into that context
that's cool
yeah so this is sort of
still in progress but it
created a connection in my head
you know we go way back and we see these
continuous ever presence you know oh we
should be sharing all of our our
experiences through video all the time
always on right and this sort of didn't
quite happen
and likewise if you go to
the
in-person scenario you have these
situations like
open plan environments where everyone's
in the same open space sitting together
and recently i was speaking to someone
who studies these open plan environments
and they said that one of the major
reasons that these things fail
is that you know there's yes there's
interaction but there's also just so
much interference that's ridiculous and
the way to get these things to succeed
is to have
a an excuse basically so you have
something like a kitchenette
or a bathroom right where people have to
go at some point
and there have and if there just happens
to be sort of a hangout area nearby they
run into each other and they stick
and that's sort of like the
unplanned hangout right and it seems
like in some sense that's what's
happening here too
is the not that it's always on
that something like as you say like the
kids soccer game or something becomes
this uh course that brings people
together and gives them the excuse to
just have this unstructured
communication i'm wondering
where we go from there like if that's
that if her insight was right
what does that suggest for how we should
be designing these systems differently
right so it almost sounds like uh
there's an attract mode that brings you
into that space um and i do like hey i
should go talk to john tom right and
like wander down to microsoft but if we
both end up in near the same place we'd
go grab coffee
right
right i mean i do think that's an
interesting area to explore
and
even
more so is
whether it has to be synchronous right
could we create
basically a
could could you subscribe
to
some sort of stream of mine of uh
interesting
uh
video messages that i'm publishing and
that could spur some conversation that
could either be real time or could be
asynchronous i mean i do think um
that's an interesting opportunity
it's sort of like
what facebook has done although largely
in text are in pictures and the question
is whether there's a role or um there's
a way that we could enrich in that with
video i think
one of the interesting
things to keep in mind is you know what
is video really good for and not to try
to
if a lower fidelity communication
channel suffices then people aren't
going to go through the extra effort for
using video so what i think the question
really then becomes what are those
events that really
depend on video to make it worth sharing
with you or make it kind of
attractive to have something together
and i think that there could be an
interesting
opportunity to figure out how to
filter edit or subscribe to a kind of a
stream of those things that that gets
emitted or shared
and then used as a way to connect people
together at convenient times i think
that's um
one of the things that uh
we've been hearing about in looking at
video messaging is that
although skype calling is very
convenient technically it's becoming
temporally inconvenient right that i
have to dedicate a fixed block of time
that i sit down and have this
conversation and and i can't and that
can be relatively shackling that while
i'm doing that in a video call of summer
i'm not as free to go do other things
and i think that's sort of an
interesting affordance of
asynchrony if we can still make it
conversational and and quote interactive
um then it could allow us to deal with
some of the constraints of scheduling
that are inconvenient
do you have any idea where that
might end up going
um i mean i think
uh
i am not sure i mean i think there's a
lot of room for opportunity i'm um
we often
in our
in our various projects we often end up
referring to
um
a tv show called max headroom this is
again it shows my age uh but the sort of
notion that right we live in a world
where there are cameras all over the
place and maybe rather than physically
moving a camera around you just tap into
it but then the other problem is well
then how do you represent yourself but
again we live in a world where there are
displays all over the place and so maybe
there's an opportunity to co-opt both
the camera and the display side and not
worry about physically
moving something around as much as sort
of creating or co-opting out of
things that are just everywhere that
that's a
we keep
kind of dancing around that idea of um
not having to worry about
locomoting which is frankly
the boring part about using a beam um
moving from point a yeah yeah moving to
point a to point b you're driving along
and going around that's the boring part
the interesting part is that when you
kind of oh
really is that what you is that what
you're saying you just sort of when you
use the locomotion to direct your
attention and that that sort of um
engage people the sort of the local
emotion not the locomotion that's the
more interesting uses of that um and i
think that might be more interesting to
to think about
you know that would really allow you to
beam places like not worry about
locomoting there and but have the impact
of being there i think is the
interesting opportunity
and the back
movies right but
sky
and even if you move it to the
to uh to a cell phone you still need the
end motion you need
you have motions that are
uh you can control it probably by arrows
and move it around
so how how do you compensate from that
when you have alpha we control the robot
to move as a real person not
not as something i can move around
because i read that pressed right on the
keyboard and
turned it on yeah
and not
i'm not sure if this is addressing your
question but i think the other
opportunity there is that we live in a
world where
everyone's kind of carrying a camera and
it might be interesting to be able to
pick which view
you want rather than physically moving a
camera around you just sort of hop from
camera to camera until you find the view
that you want and so it's sort of
controlling your view instead of
moving one around just you move your
point of view to whichever one captures
the view that you're interested in
we've thought about crowdsourcing that
view as well
so just an opinion question
given your experience with um
i guess of course kids
the uh
what do you think of vine
like
in a sense this is a sort of a viney
kind of yeah like
what's it what's it where's that going
um that's interesting um
so
what i like about this
kind of
explosion of video messaging tools is
that people have been allowed to explore
what constraints
that define the medium are the most
interesting so
the thing about vine being so short
six seconds um
i think has actually in our interviews
shown up as um
almost
a passing fad it almost seems to be in
the decline in terms of popularity
because what's happened with that six
seconds it's made it so precious that
people have
uh
moved to very very highly produced and
edited videos which is just a lot a lot
of work and and then it's raised the bar
so high that i no longer
do we we keep running into people who
say oh i used to do vines but i don't do
it anymore i watch vines but i don't
make them anymore because the bars risen
so high to cram all that creativity in
those six seconds that it's not
something that
it's not in my range anymore
and so i think that i think has been
curious to me
i love how snapchat has been co-opted or
it's i you know people it gets a lot of
press for being this medium for sexting
or or having things disappear because
they're embarrassing but i don't think
what
our understanding of how people are
using snapchat is that
it relieves me totally of all the burden
of managing you know
where videos are uh like my inbox right
i don't have to worry about cleaning it
out it just automatically expires out
and
it enables a certain kind of
communication because it's known to be
ephemeral that i wouldn't do if i had
that risk of being around that's not
anywhere near sexting as much as it's
just sort of goofy and um and fun and
kind of it's what connects me to you in
a special way that you know i don't want
shared or broadcast around so i think
it's been really interesting to watch
how
each tool offers some kind of hook of a
constraint and that constraint can get
co-opted or used in the way it was
intended to but it ends up taking a life
of its own but right the vine thing i
think
it it has this sort of i think
unintended side effect that in order to
get that into the six seconds it's it's
become sort of out of
everyday use
other thoughts questions
all right
here thank you
you